good morning i'm tracy lathrop i'm Kamel
Nanjiani and we are so excited to
announce this year's Oscar nominees but
I have a confession I've actually never
watched the announcements live before
this is the second time in my life I've
gotten up early for Oscar nominations
the first time was last year when he
watched this broadcast to see if my wife
and I were gonna get nominated although
that time I was in bed I was wearing
this exact same outfit so not wrinkly
yeah yeah I've been you know steaming it
in the shower there's a little trick for
you guys by the way we did get down
there I know it's very exciting but so
let's not keep anyone else out there
waiting here are the nominees for
performance by an actress in a
supporting role Amy Adams in Vice Marina
de tavera in drama Regina King in if
Beale Street could talk Emma Stone in
the favorite and Rachel Weisz in the
favorite very early in the morning right
very early yeah okay
I haven't had coffee but jumping-jacks
have been done I think I can guess why
they picked me to do this one it's for
achievement and costume design The
Ballad of Buster Scruggs black panther
the favorite Mary Poppins returns and
Mary's Mary Queen of Scots I'm gonna
solid eight minutes of sleep right now
he's perfect for me anymore is too much
here are the nominees for achievement in
sound mixing Black Panther Bohemian
Rhapsody first man Roma and a star is
born what did you have for breakfast oh
I'll tell you after they told me next
time and now for the nominees for
achievement in sound editing Black
Panther movie new Rhapsody first man a
quiet place and Roma I am serious I like
this we're really moving it along I
wonder if there's some kind of record we
could break for best animated short film
to go okay
animal behavior Wow
make afternoon one small step and
weekends you know when my alarm went off
this morning it felt like I'd been
punched in the face it was me I punched
you and now here are the nominees for
Best live action short film detainment
foes Marguerite
mother and skin I had four alarms that
went off this morning really my first
one off and I screamed at the top of my
lungs one offer 1:15 a.m. for Original
Score black panther black Klansmen
if Beale Street could talk I love dogs
and Mary Poppins returns do you love
dogs
I do love dogs I love all animals meet
you here are the nominees for
achievement in film editing black
Klansmen Bohemian Rhapsody the favorite
green book and vice you know I told him
instead of 5:20 why don't they do it at
5:15 a.m. and they were like that's way
too early you got to wake up at 1:15 I
woke up at 11:30 do you mind if I take
this one okay for performance by an
actor in a supporting role
mahalo ally in green book Adam driver in
black Klansmen Sam Elliott in a star is
born Richard II grant and can you ever
forgive me and Sam Rockwell invites did
get up at 1:30 but I fell asleep like I
was only through the cold open of my
first dream and Here I am the cold open
yeah at the table if that I can't wait
to find out what happens you're so lucky
you got to dreams yeah I never made it
to a draw you didn't know oh my god no
my seven minutes was rough well we still
have more nominee announcements we'll be
right back at 5:30 and 30 seconds which
is not enough time for me to make a
wardrobe change I'm gonna take a quick
nap hopefully get through act 1 I'm
gonna do jumping jacks we'll be right
back
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
for those just joining us good morning
it's still very early for those watching
welcome back
and now for the rest of the
announcements for Best Foreign Language
Film Capernaum
Lebanon Cold War Poland never look away
Germany Roma Mexico and shoplifters
Japan how's my posture oh it's flawless
I should take a picture and try and
recreate it for Best Documentary Short
subject black sheep endgame lifeboat
a night at the garden and period end of
sentence
nicely done assistant it should be at
the end of that whole run well done well
done for Best Documentary Feature free
solo Hale County this morning this
evening minding the gap of fathers and
sons and RBG you think this is good you
should see me at 2:00 p.m. that's when
I'm really hitting my stride here are
the nominees for achievement in
production design
Black Panther the favorite first man
MARY POPPINS returns and roma ID bananas
for breakfast
really yeah no peanut butter no cereal
no protein of any kind no okay for
achievement in cinematography Cold War
the favorite never look away Roma and a
star is born
[Applause]
here we go for achievement in visual
effects Avengers infinity war
Christopher Robin first man ready player
one and solo a Star Wars story
I'm very impressed I can read all these
I couldn't spell my name right now I'm
pretty sure here are the nominees oh
that's yours
okay sorry here we go here are the
nominees for achievement in makeup and
hairstyle yes better you do this one
border Mary Queen of Scots and vice in a
trivial now in there yeah may 3 in that
category at least we in that category
it's a guilt thing keep going I'm sure
thank you here's a nominees for Best
Animated Feature Film Incredibles 2
I love dog
Mirai Ralph breaks the internet and
spider-man into the spider-verse all
those movies are great for original song
all the stars from Black Panther I'll
fight from RBG the place where lost
things go from Mary Poppins returns
shallow from a star is born and when a
cowboy trades his first four wings from
the Ballad of Buster Scruggs
well time thank you here are the
nominees for adapted screenplay
[Music]
The Ballad of Buster scrubs Joel Cohen
and Ethan Coen black Klansmen Charlie
Wachtel and David Rabinowitz and Kevin
Willmott and Spike Lee can you ever
forgive me
Nicole Hall of Center and Jeff Whitty if
Beale Street could talk Barry Jenkins
and a star is born Eric Roth and Bradley
Cooper and will fetters thanks if we get
to be very excited oh it's exciting for
everybody listening okay
almost everyone mind oh you know what
can I can I take this one yes that's
fine back fond memories that's right
this is all you go here are the nominees
for original screenplay the favorite
Debra Davis and Tony McNamara for reform
Paul Schrader Green Book NIC Val alonga
Rhine curry Peter Farrelly's Roma
Alfonso Cuaron and vice Adam aqui
are you gonna sleep out this you're
gonna just have your day oh I'm probably
gonna go work out yeah I'm lying and now
for performance by an actor in a leading
role
Christian Bale invites
Bradley Cooper in a star is born Willem
Dafoe at eternity gates
rami malek in Bohemian Rhapsody and
Viggo Mortensen in green book meet you
I'm gonna go work out probably for three
to four hours really yeah I do pull-ups
push push downs here we go performance
by an actress in a leading role galicia
yalitza apareció in roma Glenn Close in
the white Olivia Colman in the favorite
Lady Gaga in a star is born and Melissa
McCarthy in can you ever forgive me
dreams just come and true out here here
are the nominees for achievement in
directing black clansmen Spike Lee cold
war baubles have letovsky the favorite
jurgis lanthum us Roma Alfonso Cuaron
and Vice Adam McKay I'm gonna walk out
oh my god here it is the final one is a
big one together let's do this together
here we go and finally here are the film
selected as Best Picture nominees black
panther Kevin Feige producer black
Klansmen Sean McKittrick Jason Blum
Raymond Mansfield Jordan Peele and Spike
Lee producers Bohemian Rhapsody
Graham King producer the favorite Cece
Dempsey a guy me lean Maggie day and
Jurgis Lancer most producers greenbook
Jim Burke Charles V Wesler Ryan Kirti
Peter Farrelly and Nick Val illunga
producers Roma Gabriella Rodriguez and
Alfonso Cuaron producers a star is born
bill Gerber Bradley Cooper and Lynette a
love Taylor producers
and the eighth and final nominee vice
didi gardener Jeremy kleiner Adam McKay
and Kevin Messick producers Wow
congratulations all the nominees thank
you everyone for joining us and watch
the 91st Oscars Sunday night February
24th on ABC
[Applause]
[Music]